a Japanese fella
has has just spent fourteen thousand
dollars to make himself look like a
border collie he spent it on a costume
mercifully this was not a a very
extensive hair plug surgery or any other
cosmetic surgery it's just it's a
costume it's very convincing costume uh
he he goes by the name Toco
and he just shared a video of him
stepping out in public for the first
time rolling around in the park in front
of children dressed up as a dog
uh he has 42 000 subscribers on YouTube
and this is not just a prank or
something which would be kind of funny
he he sincerely wants to be an animal
what's saddest about it is he seems to
be somewhat conscious of the of the
problem here you see that he says the
problem he says do you remember your
dreams from when you were little well
I'm just doing that as an adult that's
the problem